foreign
hello everyone welcome to this machine
learning project for beginners in 2023
by simply learn
this video will help you with all the
concept and give you ample hands-on
experience building machine learning
models
we have an experienced instructor who
will take you through this Project's
video
but before we start let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
so in today's session we will go through
her disease prediction using machine
learning after that we will move on to
the next project which is hate speech
detection using machine learning and at
the end we will see how to detect fake
news using machine learning hope you
guys are ready to learn something new
so without any further delay let's get
started so cardiovascular disease it
still is the number one killer
um over 12 million people die from
cardiovascular diseases every day and
what we have learned so far
um is that these some of these deaths
are preventable and so there's quite a
lot of research that is going on uh both
in the lab and in the field and as we
will see here in the area of data
science that is helping to make a
difference and so there's the famous
Framingham heart study started way back
in 1948 and continues to to date in its
third generation of participants but
this study was uh instrumental in US
beginning to collect data specifically
for studying heart disease it's now been
extended to start study other kinds of
diseases but we can use the data which
is now you know I amassed several um
thousands of participants and we can use
this data applying machine learning
techniques to help us understand
the disease how it is manifested how it
you know what are the signs and symptoms
of the disease and then use that also to
uh you know predict the presence of the
potential presence of the disease
um in some in asymptomatic patients and
so help to guide them such that they do
not develop the disease also help those
who have developed disease what steps
can be taken to reduce their risk of
dying from the disease so machine
learning has been very helpful to
Medical practitioners in the field of
cardiovascular disease as well as other
diseases if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
I talk about the
step on I want you to keep these five
steps in mind right I use the acronym of
Afters to help you remember
um you know first there's the
acquisition of the data or acquiring the
data then you will filter and clean the
data and then there are this
transforming the data then you explore
the data then you split the data so I
think of it kind of like you are
following a recipe so of course you
first have to gather all the ingredients
together that's the acquire or the
acquisition of data States then next is
you will be filtering your data similar
to if you are baking a cake you want to
filter and sift your flour and other dry
ingredients to make sure that it's clear
and clean and so too with the data we
want to make sure that the data is
accurate and that is suitable and then
um you know when you're baking a cake or
even making bread or you know any kinds
of recipe sometimes it requires you to
transform the ingredients and similarly
when you just like you would be melting
the butter
um taking it from solid to liquid we
need sometimes to transform our data
from uh Text data to numerical data or
transform feet to meters you know
there's always some kind of
transformation of our data is concerned
so that we have one accurate data and we
have a uniformity of the data that is
suitable for our model requirements then
the next step is after we've sort of
transformed the data and we have it
uniform we do an exploration of the data
and this is where you get the
understanding of your data so there is
some exploratory data analysis
um you know there's lots of General
version of plots so for visualizing so
there are some patterns and certain
Trends in the data that you will begin
to understand as you explore your data
and that will guide the kind of machine
model that you'll be able to build from
your data and sometimes you will go back
to the transformation or even the
filtering stage so there's kind of a
cyclic process here until you get your
data in a state that is just right for
making generating the model and then
once you get to that state there's
splitting off the data so you first are
going to split into uh the X thetas the
X variables and the y That's provided
that you're doing some kind a particular
kind of machine learning model meaning
that you're making models where the
labels are important
or maybe not but you will require
splitting and then there's another split
that you do more of a horizontal split
so you split your data more sometimes 80
20 or even 70 30 so that you can save
some or reserve some for the testing so
the first uh 70 you will use for
training your models and then the 30
you'll use to test the performance of
your model and evaluate it and then
decide how and when if you need to make
some changes so that you can improve the
performance of your model so those are
the main five main stages there are
others that are involved and will see
those as we go along but you want to
remember acquiring filtering
transforming exploring and then finally
splitting up the data before you start
modeling so acquiring data acquisition
is the first first stage of any machine
learning project and so there are
various Ways by which you can acquire
the data that you need it's important
that that data is suitable of course to
the problem the business problem the uh
societal problem you know whatever the
issue is the phenomenon that you are
trying to model or or to learn or to
gain Insight from you want to First make
sure that you have suitable data so you
can get the data by scraping the
internet you can extract that data from
another source you you can
be involved in your own data collection
in terms of whether it's a survey or
some type of other activity and or you
may have to combine data from different
sources but these are ways that you can
actually acquire the data that you need
and so sometimes it's just simply
getting the data from the internet as we
will be doing my data acquisition
stage is actually quite short because I
am using data that is available when it
comes to the Framingham heart study data
set it's quite popular a lot of people
use it you can get it from of GitHub you
can get it from many different sources
you can Google just Google Framingham
hard study data set and it'll show up
and so I've downloaded it and saved it
to my computer and so I'm going to so of
course first before I can load it onto
my notebook which here is uh the Google
collab notebook and so I need certain
tools right so these are the tools that
we need to start our
um you know project and so first we will
have the importing of pandas
numpy matplotlib
scipy escaler and Seabourn so a pandas
is for the data frame numpy's for
numerical type activities my matplot lab
is for our graphs basic graphs and
charts scipis for statistic sklearn as
well as while Seabourn is also for
graphing and SQL and the sport when we
actually do the modeling so we will
import those by running this
cell here and once that has run we will
then you install I need to install
install this uh Pi read stat because my
data set is in the sav form now yours
may be in Excel or CSV so you would use
a different uh function here method here
for loading your data set but this is
what I'm doing so now we have all of
these modules now I can install my
pirate stat
module and then I can load my data so
for that I am going to make sure that my
data set is actually
loaded here
and
so I'm going to
make sure that I'm loading this data set
that I need from my
computer and
here it's going to tell me that this is
a temporary load and that's okay because
we can always load it again so now that
I have all of these in place now I can
go ahead and actually read my data set
in into my notebook
and so once I've done that then I can
take a look at my data set by looking at
the first five rows and so that's what
the dot head method does
uh then I can see you know I'll give an
example just a snapshot of what is
contained in my data set in terms of the
types of columns or types of features
and then what the rows look like so it's
showing here that I have 34 columns in
all but we don't know how many rows so
that's where the dot shape comes in so
if I do that it gives me it says that I
have 4
578 rows the first value it's the number
of rows and the second is the number of
columns as we saw here then if I want to
just take a more detailed look at what
is in my data set I use the dot info
method and that gives me a list of all
of the columns in my data set as well as
whether those columns are filled
contained information or not to the
extent that so we have four thousand
five hundred and seventy eight rows and
so we see ages all of the age uh rows
are filled but not so much with
cholesterol so anything that is less
than
4578 we know that it's missing some
values also this dot info gives you
information about the type of uh data
that's in each column so summer floats
and others are categories and then the
final thing we do when it comes to just
looking at our data is using the dot
describe method so I can
show here in terms of what the average
value is for all of the features and
then I can see what the minimum value
and the Max and 25th and 75th percentile
and so on so for that I've used the dots
describe and so I've transformed The
Matrix so that it's in a different
Arrangement and then I've also applied
this display dot float so that I can
remove
um the extraneous
numbers after the decimal point so
that's what we would do when it comes to
you know just acquiring the data and
taking a look at it and making sure that
it is what we wanted it to be so after
you have acquired your data this is the
this is where you will do the filtering
of your data and the main idea of the
filtering is to get rid of the errors
duplications any kind of data that
doesn't belong that is not going to be
helpful to you in your modeling process
as well as looking for outliers and any
kind of extraneous type of info that we
may have to make some uh do some
transformation to depending and so we
would look for outliers of course then
we'd see if you know there are values
that are entered that don't belong we
also want to get rid of duplicates
because that could cause bias and
inefficient modeling and we also want to
look for invalid data right so if it's
supposed to be measurements of heights
then we want to make sure that it's all
numerical and that there is no text in
there
Etc so that's what the filtering is in a
nutshell so let's do some filtering of
our data so for the filtering I noticed
that we had first of all when I did do
the dot describe now that mind you that
gives you only the numerical or values
that are labeled floats in this case not
the ones that are categorical and if we
looked at the dot info method right
we'll see that there is uh as far as the
seventh column or the eighth column is
concerned there's a PID or some kind of
ID and it's labeled as a float but that
is it you know it's not an in
information that we can use for our
modeling and then there was another uh
ID measurement somewhere in here in
terms of the ID type so I wanted to
First go ahead and remove those two
columns so I'm using the dot drop Mouse
method I put the tuned column names into
square brackets as a list and then I
identify the axis 1 to note that these
are in the columns
um ID so once we do that I reassign that
back to the data frame we can do simply
do an in place equals true as an option
so I do that and now I've gotten rid of
that and if I do dot shape again we
would see that now we have actually
32 rows to 32 columns now and we do have
457
rows so we have
so one I get rid of the columns the PID
and the ID type and I check my the
dimensions of my data frame I can see
that instead of 34 I now have
32 columns and I still have the same
number of rows so now we've gotten rid
of those
um you know invalid in in pieces of
information they are not important to
our modeling secondly now we want to
look for missing values and that's where
we use the is null so what that'll do it
will show us wherever there are values
missing it will say true if the values
are there and they're valid that well
whether they're valid as long as their
value is there it will say false so we
want to get a count of all the missing
values in each of the columns so we
would use the is null and then we would
add the dot sum to it so it'll tell us
for LDL cholesterol 67 values are
missing for diabetes status 11 and so on
and if I want to get that as a
percentage of The Columns of the total
number of observations I can then do
divide by the length and multiply I by
100 to get a percentage so for the LDL
cholesterol column
1.464 percent of the values are missing
so that's how we would identify the
missing values now there are other ways
we can look for amazing values and that
is using this missing goal module and
once I import that then I can use the s
m s n o to get a visual of my data frame
so I would use
msno.bar and I would put the name of my
data frame into the uh as an argument
and that is going to give me this lovely
bar chart where we can see in anything
that is not the length of the other bars
we know that there are some missing
values now our data set does not contain
a lot of missing values so the bars look
almost identical but just as an example
alternatively we can use the dot matrix
method and what that does it gives you
to a printout of the Matrix where when a
missing a number or value is missing you
will get a white space
not much missing so not much to look for
then finally when it comes to missing
values visualizing Missions at missing
values we can use the heat map right we
can now do the msno heat map and that
gives us some idea of the
um you know the correlation between the
missingness of one column relative to
another
and so we can see that of course
certainly glucose
um times HDL so this is a interaction
column or feature created from the
glucose and the HDL measures and
certainly that is going to be correlated
with HDL cholesterol because it's
generated from that
um and so we can get an idea in terms of
the relationship between the missingness
of one feature relative to another
because that's going to determine how we
deal with these missing values right so
depending on the nature of the
missingness whether it's related to
another column or not or whether it's
related to the Target column or outcome
variable that we're trying to model for
or predict then we're going to treat
those differently from those that mean
who's missing this are not correlated
with the target variable so you want to
Bear those things in mind
so when it comes to dealing with the
missing values there are a number of
things that we can do now
we are in this case uh for example we're
going to delete the rows from two of The
Columns where they're missing values in
fact not delete we're going to impute or
we're going to fill those with the mean
of that column so in the first place
when it comes to the LDL cholesterol
we're going to fill in all the missing
values with the mean for the LDL
cholesterol similarly we're going to
fill in all the missing values for the
fasting blood sugar with the mean of the
fasting blood sugar and so once I run
that that's what's going to happen and
so if I do that now I can see that when
it comes to LDL cholesterol there is no
longer
missing values as well as for the
fasting blood sugar so they've now been
filled in and so for the other column
where there's still some missing values
because the percentages are so low we
can go ahead and simply drop the rows
that contain missing values and that's
what we use the drop and A4 and we apply
that to our data frame and then
reassign it back to the data frame we
can also alternatively do and in place
equals true when we so we don't have to
reassign it it will actually happen to
the data frame itself but we now have
that and then if we check for
missingness we see now all of our
columns are complete so we are good to
go as far as missing values are
concerned no more missing values
that's one of the ways there are other
ways to um you know Python and sklearn
comes with some very fancy modules or or
um different programs algorithms that
you can use for filling in missing data
doing whether it's the mean or the
median or the mode depending on what
type of variable it is but these are
some of the basic ways you can either
fill in with the mean using the fill n a
or in this case if the missingness is
um usually not more than 10 percent then
you can go ahead and drop those columns
um so now we have accounted for all our
missing values and so the last thing it
would do for filtering as far as our
data set is concerned is to check for
any duplication and our data frame there
are no duplication as far as the entire
rows are concerned right there are no
two rows that are the same now if we
wanted to look for duplication by way of
say you know one column or group of
columns then we could use
the the subset inside of the drop
underscore duplication duplicates method
right so this is giving you info here
about this uh method and it's showing
you that you know by default it's
there's nothing that you will be using
as kind of a subset so it's looking for
the entire row and you know if it does
find it it will generally
um keep the first and you can stipulate
whether you want to keep the first or
keep the last and so that's because we
don't have anything any miss any
duplications then we can't really um we
don't have to use this so that's what we
would do for filtering we would First
Look for missing values
um in this case I also got rid of
firstly the uh those PID numbers because
we're not important to our modeling then
I checked four missing values and I
dealt with that and then I checked for
duplicates and I also dealt with that
so that's how the basic filtering method
would occur so the third step in our
machine learning process is that a
transformation and remember these steps
can be fluid there's no hard and fast
rules because as you will see there's
some
um there might be some filtering going
on in transformation and vice versa but
essentially transformation
um is mainly about changing the values
into a form that is suitable for
modeling
so first and foremost the models can
only accept numerical values and so if
we want to use a certain column a
certain feature in our model algorithm
then we would have to change any text
into a type of numbers whether that's
integers or floats so that's the main
model uh transformation that happens
there's also
um sometimes you know some mapping going
on where we may be changing a continuous
variable into some kind of a bin
grouping binning
um also there is of course
the formatting when it comes to date you
know if we're doing time series type of
of modeling then we would want usually
when we get the data set it comes in as
text as far as the date values are
concerned and so we would have to
convert them to the special python date
type
um
pictures so those are some examples of
the transformation data transformation
that we do when it comes to machine
learning there are quite a few more but
we'll just touch on some of the basics
for now so the transformation that we're
going to do here so first let's remind
ourselves what kind of data we have in
our data set and I think I made some
changes so let me go back to I'm going
to run all of this again just to make
sure
um I'm giving you everything so this is
we load the data the then we did
um we what were some of the other
changes we got rid of these IDs then we
looked at the missing values then we
actually filled in those two columns
with the mean and
the also dropped other columns with
missing values so that's the main steps
that we've done so far so now with the
data transformation so if we look at our
you know data set as far as the data
frame is concerned we see we have floats
and we have some categorical variables
some of which should be very it should
be categoricals others possibly not but
um so for example we have these date
values that we're going to need to take
care of if we want to use them in the
model as they are intended
um also things like gender now here it
is a float so we also look at this
diabetic status so that's if we saw what
the categories are so it's non-diabetic
diabetic so just two categories so this
is labeled here in the data frame if I
can find means diabetic status right and
it's oh it is categorical here so
um right now it's fine using it as
categorical we can then see what those
values look like in terms of if we
wanted to get an idea of the
distribution of diabetics in our data
set we would do a values counts
and that would give us what that looks
like if we want to do it as percentage
we would do normalize equals true and so
.035 are diabetic very low percentage of
diabetes diabetics in this data set but
if we wanted to convert that to a
numerical say we want to include it in
our model then we can use the dot
replace method and how that works is you
identify the column using uh calling it
out with the square brackets and you dot
replace and inside of that method we're
going to include the categories that are
the original feature and then as a list
and then we include another list for the
values that we'd like to replace these
with so if I run that so now I'm
reassigning it back to the data frame so
it's actually actually changing my data
frame and then if I do the unique that's
what happens now if we were to run this
again a second time
here then we would see that instead of
saying non-diabetic and diabetic it's
now saying one and two
so that's one of the other ways this is
a this is a second way that we can do
some kind of data transformation and
that is using uh the pandas get dummy
and it's usually used when we have these
categorical variables that we want to
change into some numerical values so
that we can now include them in our
model and so what to get dummies does is
actually going to
um give each of the category
its own numbers and so if we ran that we
see here now it's doing one and we
wherever there's that person is actually
diabetic you would get a one here and
then that person would be a zero so it's
taken that one column and split it into
two columns and so now we see whenever
there's a diabetic it's one in this
First Column and if that person is now
um if that person is not diabetic then
the one would be in in a in a different
uh column for the diabetics for the
non-diabetics so that's how that would
work now if I were to say use this with
a different column that maybe we can do
the age group
feature and if I ran that so the first
thing we would do is let us
see
what are the categories for age group so
if we did that we put our age group
column in here and I want to make sure
that I get the name correct so I would
do age group and I would put that in
here in place and that would give me so
there are the age groups of this 26 to
40 and 41 to 60 and 70. so 1 2 3 4 5 age
groups so we could go ahead and we could
do something like we did here
for the diabetics column and so we put
that in there we now are going to
replace our age group so we have all of
these as
the various column headings now oh and
we're going to use that here
and this is also going to be age group
as well
and so for these now what we're going to
do is we're going to replace
these with actual text that we can use
so less than 25 we're going to call
these the young uh the youth let's say I
owe you th and then the next grouping
we're gonna say Young
adults
and then the 41 to 45
we're going to call these adults
then for 56 to 70 we'll say middle
aged and then we will say old right so
those will be the categories that we are
replacing them with so we can run that
and now if we were to do the values
count we can see how those
are distributed in our data set
so there we have it we have adults young
adults middle age and if I wanted to do
a plot of that I would do kind
equal
four so that's using the built-in python
plotting method
and that would generate this lovely plot
so we can see the distribution and so
that's how that would work and now if we
also wanted to say do they get dummies
what that's going to do it's going to
create a new column for each of our
categories
and I think we did that
now we have one two three four five
columns and of course here this person
is a doll so it's one here and zero
elsewhere the first person is a young
adult so it's one there and zero
elsewhere and so on so that's what this
get dummy does it's going to create an
additional column for each of the
categories so that's one of the ways
that we usually convert categorical
variables to numerical variables now you
want to be careful that there aren't
um excess of categories right because
then you have the curse of
dimensionality as far as your model is
concerned so we want to avoid that
there's other method here we can do is
to use the label encoder and so we
import that from the pre-processing
module and once we've done that we
create an instance or we get a a
blueprint of that out algorithm we
assign that to the name l e and now we
can use it here we're using the model
here and we're going to fit it and
transform it on the data set for gender
and I already did that here but that is
what if we so if we took a look at the
this column
as it was originally in the data set so
let's do a value
counts on that
and that would show us how many males
and how many females
um so it's giving us that two and one
and I'm not sure which is which but we
can also always check the data source
and find out so if we do I think I
already applied that to my data set
which is why so let's go back
so if we wanted to look at the
categories in a categorical variable of
course we always we can use the uh dot
unique and that would give us just the
name of the categories and so we see
those categories here but if we wanted
to find out what the distribution of
those categories are that's why we use
the values count so here we're seeing
for the BMI grouping we have four
categories now we could do um use the
label encoder module
that is built into
python so we just load it
um into our data to our notebook and
once we have used that we create an
instance we can use it to transcript and
transform the feature or the column
value and then we can see how it is
distributed so what it is done it's
converted all each of the names of the
categories into numbers so now we have
overweight is one and normal is zero and
morbid obesity is now three and
underweight is two so that's how that
would work now the final transformation
is that of transforming uh converting
the text to a date time feature so we
want to convert the text date
to the pandas daytime feature right so
it's state as a text
and we're going to now convert that to
pandas daytime and for that we use two
underscore dates time and we include
that column inside of the parentheses as
the argument to that function so once we
do that so it's PD to underscore dates
time with the column identified here and
we reassign that back to our data frame
so now when we look at our data frame
and here we we had date time as a float
or whatever it was before now it is an
actual pandas date time object so those
are the main basic types of
transformation that you would do to your
data set in preparation for modeling so
the fourth step in our data science
machine learning project is that of
exploration data exploration or
Eda exploratory data analysis is an
extremely important step in our modeling
process right this is where we get an
insight into the trends and the
relationships that may exist in our data
there we can find what the anomalies are
we may also do some univariate biferate
or even multi-period analysis and if
necessary where we want to determine a
relationship but it's not an obvious
linear relationship then we would do
some hypothesis testing whether that's
between two of the predictor variables
or between a predictor variables and the
outcome and of course all of this is
going to involve data visualizations so
this is where you're going to generate
your charts and graphs and
um other types of visualizations that
would help you to understand and what is
the information contained in your data
because looking at the numbers and uh
data frame that is generally not going
to give you all of the insights that you
that is is contained in there and so
we're going to do some of that now so
when it comes to
exploratory data analysis right so the
first thing is understanding the
distribution of the values in your
variables right whether they are
continuous variables
integer variables so the numerical can
be integer or they can be continuous and
then for the categorical whether it's a
binary variable or there are more than
two categories so looking firstly at our
Target variable which is CHD coronary
heart disease we can do a value counts
with the normalize equals true and that
gives us a nice table showing the
percentage of values or observations in
each of the categories similarly we can
add the Dot Plot with the kind equal bar
and generate a graph for that and so we
see significant imbalance which we're
going to have to deal with before
modeling but
um another way we can look at the
distribution of variable goals relative
to one of the features so now we're
moving on from you you know the universe
type of analysis to buy variate analysis
so we want to look at all of the
variables as far as sex is concerned
right so we are going to use the group
by Method and then to that we're going
to apply the mean so what the group by
does it creates a data frame a separate
data frame for each of the categories in
a particular variable so here we have
sex and it's going to
divide our data set our data frame into
the two categories and then find the
mean for each of those values so so if
we ran that what it shows us here now we
have age and cholesterol and smoking and
so for the gender labeled one we have an
age an average age of 40.979 and for the
gender labeled two we'd have an average
age of 40.84 so not much difference as
far as the age is concerned when it
comes to cholesterol certainly there is
a difference the gender age is up 1.19
and those who are labeled two are
1.07 and so if we
um just from the fact that there are
higher percentage of smokers in category
one I'm going to assume those are the
male I may be wrong but that's my
assumptions over and then
um there is a 13 you know as far as
smoking is concerned there's a 13
percent
um measure of of smokers and then
fasting blood sugar and so if we can
look at all of the values
um that we have here and see if there
are any differences as far as the gender
is concerned now if we wanted to say
just focus on our outcome variable right
we can just choose that and that would
give us the distribution as far as the
gender is concerned so for one uh there
is a a point of 0.04 average
heart disease whereas for two it's a
point zero one five nine so we can you
know choose other values here to to
select from our sex group by but that's
how you would do
a binary type a bivariance type of
analysis and you can also plot that as
well if you did plot dot kind
let's see kind equals bar here that
would give you a general so now we can
see here as far as the gender is concern
the percentage of those with heart
disease
and that's uh that is binary bivariate
distribution now because I wanted to
convert those and based on what I had
seen before in my table and I just want
to go back to that to remind me again
and I'm going to remove that because I
am saying here that
2 is female let's change that and that
one is male
and usually there's a info package which
comes with these data sets so you can
confirm that but uh so if we now instead
of having the zeros in one which is good
for modeling but when we want to do
graphs and charts you know the
exploratory type data analysis then we
need to have that labeled so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to create a
separate
um
you know column an additional column now
for gender or for sex and I'm going to
call this
um the categorical version so here
um I do that and now if I do my group by
again this time with my new column then
I can see female and males there and so
now what I want to do is generate a plot
and resolve we can do it directly from
you know using Python's syntax but if we
wanted to use the SNS
um module right so SNS allows us to do
categorical variables and so you can use
the female male categories and actually
generate a plot so we have a heart
disease and I'm going to replace this
with our
new um
pictures I want to make sure that I'm
identifying the right column and so now
we can see a lovely graph that shows us
the average
um you know what average male percentage
of heart disease is relative to the
average female percentage of heart
disease so on average males are for
points well I'm saying 4.5 something
percent whereas with a female it's
probably 1.8 percent or so and so that's
what that 1.6 actually so so that's how
we would do our
bivariate type of analysis in general
right you can do the group by and then
generate a chart or graph and support
select a column in particular or we can
actually use our cat plot where we
identify the data frame then we identify
the why you know values right so those
are going to be what's you know is on
the x-axis and then we choose the
particular column so now for the x-axis
and we can see what that looks like so
that's uh you know we can also do things
like we can do instead of just a cat
plot we can do a uh scatter plot
um for our variables and here we're
going to have to use uh make sure that
we're using you know continuous
variables even though there's some
variables in here that are labeled
continuous that are not so what we're
going to do is we're going to go back to
our
um list of variables and at least see so
I'm assuming that this is a continuous
variable and we're going to put that in
here and then we'll choose another
continuous variable and we put that in
here and now we can generate a scatter
plot for those two variables right and
so that's what our scatter plot looks
like and I'm going to just kind of make
it a little bigger and for that I have
to make sure
that I have the object so I can do PLT
dot bigger and then I can do big
big size
and I'm going to say 12 by 7 or so so
um yeah so we need to have the equal
sign there you see how it was telling me
something is wrong so now we have that
um now what does this mean let's see
what happens here
and it is saying that I need another
comma okay very good so now we have our
plot and it's you know bigger and we see
we have some outliers here that's the
other thing that data exploration helps
you to see these outliers and the these
anomalies right and so we'd have to
figure out how we're going to deal with
it so certainly when it comes to the
cholesterol measure there is some there
is an outlier
um if we wanted now this is the
bivariate analysis we can make this a a
trivariate analysis by adding Q equals
to
um in this case we're going to use our
Target variable and if we ran that now
we get a plot and we can see where the
those who are considered having had the
heart disease they are how they're
distributed so that's what we would do
as far as these things are concerned now
so if we wanted to we could also use the
sns.reg or regplot and what that does it
gives us a trend line so we can see if
the variables the two variables that
we're plotting if there is any uh linear
relationship between those variables and
so that would be this trend line
depending on the
um
depending on the angle of the trend line
if it's a steep angle that we know that
there is a strong relationship if it's a
small angle then there's a weak
relationship if it's a straight line
then there is no relationship so that's
the general just of uh doing these type
of bivariate analysis for our variables
using either scatter plot or rank plot
and then when it comes to the
categorical variables we would use the
value count or we would use our group by
like we wanted to do a multivariate
analysis
right so we could separate our data
frame into categorical variables and
numerical variables so here I'm creating
a subset of categorical variables and
I'm using the select underscore D types
method and here I identify the columns
type that I want to select for so when I
run that I get only the categorical
variables or at least those that are
labeled categorical variables and so I
can now look at my variables and here
this is where I am seeing you know so we
see here that these are the different
categories but if I were to look
specifically at the variables that I am
now identifying as
categorical so we see those are the ones
with
only two three four the max here is
seven categories right and so these are
um these are the original variables
diabetic status and then 10-year update
and even there's a filter variable
created here and we have these uh
variables so this was an extra so they
bend the variables so HDL they Bend into
three groups then s b p the systolic
broad pressure they built into four
groups and BMI they also built into four
groups age they built into five so this
is all the variables where they created
additional variables so they did some
type of transformation essentially in
this data set
um and then if we wanted to we could
actually now do some separation of our
variables as far as as we can look at
and what I want to show how we did just
the numerical variables but what I
noticed was that there were some
variables that were a labeled
categorical
or not that were labeled either
floats numerical values that were not
necessarily
categorical variables and I'll give you
an example
so if we looked at the number of unique
values in some of our data set some of
our columns for example
smoking only has two unique values that
tells me it is
actually a cat worker variable but it
does not label the categorical because
it doesn't show up when we separate
those label categoricals from those
label the not label category smoking
should be categorical social sex it's
not shown up here of course our Target
variable is also categorical
then tenure debate 10-year update there
are a bunch of these variables that
actually should be labeled as category
or should be treated as categorical
um and some of them are but others
and some of them are but others are not
and so when we go to our modeling we
want to make sure that we have
transformed the variables appropriately
now let's look at uh the numerical
values choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 Plus
hours of video content for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so continuing with our
exploratory data analysis right so we're
separating out the categorical variables
at least those that are labeled
categorical but when we do our DOT
unique for the entire data set we see
that there are some cats some of these
features that are that only have two
unique set of values that should ideally
be categorical variables and they're not
so what I'm doing here is I'm going to
now
assign the entire data frame you know to
a separate data frame based on those
unique values and then I'm going to
um you know give this new
data frame well by putting it as using
dot reset index I've now converting it
to a data frame effectively and so
that's what it looks like here except
that the column labels are weird so
that's where I'm giving the the column
labels actual names features here and
categories and so one I do that now I
can
convert all of the data types
to integers because Summer floats some
are integers but what what I'm
converting to integers are use these
values right because I want to be able
to sort those values and once I'm I've
sorted those values now I well I
probably didn't need to sort it
necessarily but I am now going to uh
create a subset
of features
that have unique
categories less than 10 because those
are the true categorical variables and
so once I do that now I get a list of
these uh columns that ideally that
accurately should be labeled
as categorical and so now I can use this
list of feature name or column names to
create my true
um categorical
data's frame subset and so this is what
we have here and so once I have done
that now I I don't need to to print this
out again so I'm going to delete that
but now once I've done that now I can
use this data set which is of
categorical variables and I can produce
count plots so count plots is one of
um the plot type in
of the SNS module and that allows you to
plot a categorically labeled variables
and so you can see what those looks like
look like as far as the distribution is
concerned so if we did Count plot of
this feature now when it comes to SNS
you always have to do data and you have
to identify the data frame
and then you can identify what the X
values that you are wanting to to count
for
um essentially so now we can generate
that count plot if I spell it
correctly
and we can see here a distribution of
all of the categories
in that particular variable so
um most of the data set is made up of
those between the ages of 26 and 40 and
41 and 45 so from 26 to 55 sorry that's
the majority of and it gives you an
actual count of observations in each of
these categories so so now that these
are all categorical variables I can
include them in my for Loop so I am
using a for Loop and I'm saying for I in
and I'm enumerating over the list of
columns and so when you use the
enumerate identifies the index as well
as the value so I'm enumerating over
this list of columns and then so for
every column name I will then use that
of the first object identified for my
enumeration and that's going to be the X
and of course the data is coming from
the data frame and now I'm using
the hue
as the target variable so I can see how
each of my variable is distributed as
far as the outcome variable is concerned
now because there is such significant
imbalance there isn't much to see we you
know when it comes to the percentage of
persons with heart disease it's so low
that you know you get these very small
very low bars but that's what you would
do so we can see here for smoking so if
this is the smoking category these are
the people this is the count of persons
without without heart disease whereas
those with heart disease similarly
um so there is not much to see here but
if you had a data set where there wasn't
as much imbalance this would be
something
um very useful as far as the
distribution of our variables are
concerned
thank you
so now we are moving to our continuous
variables right and so we are looking at
those variables labeled
plots
and if we generate a subset of the data
set we would get these variables here
now we see heart disease is still here
and some of the others now what I could
do is do a subset of the data frame that
is actually
um minusing all that I have chosen for
my categorical variable so let's do that
so I'm using the
dot drop method and I'm going to drop
all of the categories that I have
uh considered now uh as all of the
columns that I consider categorical
variables so as I do that now I see that
they're all listed as float but I also
want to get rid of this date column
because it's a different type of data so
we get rid of that and now we have some
um we have our columns here actually I'm
dropping it from this data frame not the
main data frame necessarily so now I
drop that and apparently it's already
dropped from the data frame
so
let's see if I ran this again
it is
still there so why am I not able to drop
it from this data frame Siege date
access equals one there we go so now
it's dropped and now we can do some
things with our numerical data set one
of the first things that we could do is
to actually generate a
correlation Matrix and so for that we
would have the name of our data frame
and we'd use the dot core method and
that would give us a nice Matrix that
shows the correlation between each pair
of variable now because it's you know
not as easy to look at all of these
numbers and this is where the charts and
graphs makes things a whole lot easier
so we're going to use a heat map and
that will give us a nice visual as far
as the relationship
between our variables are concerned so
now I'm going to try to make this
bigger by using PLT but bigger and I'm
not sure if this is going to work but
we're going to try I may have to
actually do it inside of the heat map
hmm
function itself so we are going to do 12
and 7 and see what happens here oh that
worked so now we see our data frame as
far as the continuous variables were
concerned and where there is some
correlation now of course
this and uh the data frame we're seeing
a lot of correlation LDL is correlated
with the
the
variable that's uh created from from HDL
HDL yeah so it's also correlated
with this variable here
which is
um the cholesterol so we have LDL
cholesterol this is a
intersection or a bisection variable or
a interaction variable that's created
between LDL and cholesterol and so of
course it's going to be correlated with
LDL as well as correlated with
cholesterol so the other variables that
it's correlated with let's see anything
uh other than those mentioned not much
Happening Here and HDL cholesterol oh so
if we look at our uh Legend here though
light values is positive
strongly positive correlation whereas
the dark values are the negative
correlations and these negative
correlations are not more than minus 0.3
so not to very strong so for light
correlations though so we can see that
the passing blood sugar BMI interaction
is strongly correlated with systolic
well let me see that's about the seven
strongly
yeah that's five strongly correlated
with um mod directly correlated
with
systolic blood pressure
here we have so so there's a so as far
as the interaction variables are
concerned quite a lot so not much in
terms of inferring anything
um you know if we looked at some of
these raw values age is
not very strongly correlated with
anything so usually the heat maps are a
lot more informative but in our case
um not so much but we can do some box
plots to see how the variables the
distribution of the variables so for a
simple box plot you would simply do dot
box plot so using the built-in python
plotting but of course because the
variables are on different scales it's
really kind of doesn't show much so if
we do the facet grid now where we have a
separate box plot for each of the
variables and not only do we have a
separate box plot we can also now
um separate based on additional
variables so we can do bivariate as well
as a tri-variage type of analysis here
so here we're looking at gender versus
age and so we can get each of the age
groups as a separate plot as well as we
can see
um you know how those age groups the
count of the different number of
observations in in each of those
categories relative to the outcome
variable so we have the rows
representing the gender so we have
gender in the roles here and these are
the two genders so we'll have the male
and female so this is X sex one for this
row and sex two for the second row and
then for each of the columns now we have
of age groups so we have the young
people the 41 to 55 here and the 56 to
70 and then we have
the ones who are less than 25 and then
those that are more than 70. so we get
an idea of how the
heart disease is distributed now mind
you it's showing here this is zero and
this is one even you know ignore what
the x-axis is so this would be no heart
disease heart disease no heart disease
heart disease and so on
um and not much difference as far as the
gender it's hard to see anything clearly
uh alternatively we could
use the facet grid and instead of the
the histogram now we're using a scatter
plot and so we're looking at these two
variables comparing these um you know
the relationship between fasting blood
sugar and total cholesterol but we're
now dividing uh based on the age
grouping so we have the age groupings
here and we have uh the fasting blood
sugar versus the total cholesterol and
then we have the Hue for as far as
thought whether that person had heart
disease or not
so that's how you do some of these
bivariate and even multivariate type of
analysis
if we wanted to look at just
one you know just doing bivariate
analyzes
for a particular variable then we could
do that so here we have the X as the age
grouping and then we have y as the total
cholesterol so instead of having a
series of maps or graphs or charts this
would just be one so we can do that one
at a time so we create our uh objects
our plot objects that I'll pick an X is
equal to PLT subplot and it's
determining the size so when we do S and
S box plot where we identify the X and
the y axis from this data frame and we
say the ax is based on this ax we
defined here when we run that it gives
us this really nice graph where we can
see the relationship between the age
groups and the total cholesterol in
terms of the or the mean of these values
for each age group so we see definitely
that those under 25 had a lower a median
value as far as uh the total cholesterol
is concerned and then for the 26 to 40
we see there is definitely some type of
an outlier happening here now this is
interesting because what it's showing
here that there's a total cholesterol
outlier but remember we have different
measures for our cholesterol so if
instead of the total cholesterol we use
the LDL cholesterol in that plot
and we replaced it here so what that
would show us now is that there is no
longer an outlier in this group
so the
extreme value is actually the HDL
cholesterol because remember total
cholesterol is the sum of LDL and the
HDL so just some further insights and
then there is this uh
outlier here possibly but LDL
cholesterol you know something that you
want to be wary of you know HDL is a
healthy cholesterol
so just some ways you can gain some
insight and then finally if we were to
generate
um these box plots for each of the that
variables we can see the ones so there
we see that total cholesterol with the
outlier there and then if we were to
look for specifically
that LDL cholesterol so we see HDL so
there is the outlier in HDL and not so
much in LDL
just looking at it and so that's what
we're looking so now we've kind of
looked at all the ways we can do
exploration of our data whether it's
categorical variables using
um the count plot or numerical variables
we looked at the heat map and then we
looked at some box plots and and of
course Scatter Plots so just some ideas
of how you can explore your data there's
a whole lot more to it but just to give
you some idea but now that we have
filtered our data sets we've transformed
some of the variables now we're ready to
generate our machine learning model
so when we did our data exploration
however we learned that our Target
variable which is uh CHD or coronary
heart disease disease is significantly
imbalanced and what that means is that
there are very few observations in
one of the categories and in this case
it is the category of Interest which
represents the persons who've had heart
disease so if we do our values count we
see that of the fourth the 4500 or so
only 125 actually
are recorded as having heart disease and
if we do normalize equals true that
shows us that about
2.789 or so are those who've had heart
disease so that is would be considered
an imbalance um and if we were to look
at that graphically we'd see that in the
bar chart here
using plots dot uh kind equal barf on
the value counts alternatively we can do
a plot kind equal
pie and get par chart and I've added the
labels here as well as the Syntax for
removing some of the numbers after the
decimal point so this is just to
illustrate just how imbalanced the data
set is and so we would need to do some
kind of bootstrappings you know over
sampling to balance out that Target
variable
so before that though we first have to
we're going to do a splitting of the
data set so we would normally do two
splitting into the X and r y or the
input and output or the predictors and
the outcome variables and then we would
split that into our
train and test so if we wanted we can do
so here we see what our data frame looks
like and we're using the numerical uh
The Continuous variables
um because these are more attenuable to
smoting and we'll learn what that is in
a second but we we want to do smooth
this over sampling and so that's going
to be based on the uh continuous
variables so we've filtered out a subset
of those variables and that is going to
be our X Matrix or input Matrix or our
predictor variables so we have the shape
here
4557 by 18 columns right and then of
course the Y is simply going to be the
column for with our Target variables so
that's going to have the corresponding
Dimension you know it's a matrix but
this one has just it's just a series or
just an array whereas the others it's a
it's a two-dimensional
so we now have our X and our y so we can
go ahead and smooth our variables and
smote stands for the
synthetic minority oversampling so
because our Target outcome or category
is so low as far as the proportion is
concerned we are going to do a sampling
an over sampling but we're going to be
over sampling of the minority set to
generate synthetic observations so
that's what the smoothing does so the
first thing we do is we uh load the
algorithm into our data set so we're
going to get the small algorithm from
the uh IMB learn over sampling module
and so once we have that loaded then we
create an instance of that algorithm and
we assign it to the variable name Os or
sampling then we take that over sampling
algorithm the it's just a blueprint of
the algorithm so now we're going to use
the data to train this smote model and
and get the features so we use fit
underscore resample now with other
algorithms we use fit underscore
transform in this case we're using fit
underscore resample and the parameters
are the X Matrix first and then the Y
Matrix or the Y series and we are going
to assign the results of that fit
resample back to what would be now our
new X Matrix and our new y values
created by the oversampling so once
we've done that we can take a look at
the dimensions of these new uh objects
now for the X we see it has Dimensions
88 60 by 18. now remember our X was 45
57 by 18. so now it's 88.60 so we've
doubled the number of observations right
the number of columns remain the same
similarly for the X variable we have
doubled the number of outcomes
to match our X and so we can take a look
at that if we did a value counts on our
y series here we would see that it's
distributed
equally remember what the distribution
was here
um it was 97
to
2.78 that was the ratio now that we have
smoked the data set our new ratio is one
to one
so 50 of the observations are
those who had heart disease and 50 are
those who've had who've not so that is
what the smoking does so it has used the
uh the minority uh outcomes and over
sampled for those to create synthetic
variables and if we plotted the bar
chart here we see that the both bars are
the same using the Dot Plot if we use
SNS it gives us a nice
um colorful plot version
but we can see definitely that the count
for each category is identical now if we
wanted to look at the distribution of
these synthetic observations we could
recombine the X and the Y back into a
data frame such that we could do some
um bivariate and even multivariate type
analysis so that's what I did here so
I've assigned the X Matrix to a dative
created a data frame with it using PD
dot data frame and this DF underscore OS
is now the new uh over sampling or
smooth data frame and then I add the
outcome variable or heart disease to
that data frame so now we have a
complete data frame and we can do all
the things we did with the original data
frame here so in this case I'm creating
a scatter plot with the data frame and
I'm using BMI you choose any random uh
any one of the many variables I'm
plotting BMI versus age or age versus
BMI because
y uh versus X and I'm using heart
disease as the hue
so when I plot that I get this lovely
scatter plot here and what you see is
all of the Blues are the ones that did
not have heart disease
and now
the orange are the synthetic well mostly
mostly the synthetic observations and so
you can see how it's distributed
um as far as these two variables are
concerned you can choose any of the
other variables and substitute so we can
look at uh we had agent BMI we can do
fasting blood glucose against
um so we'll just leave the age in there
maybe he can do the fasting blood
glucose
and see so there we can see how the
synthetic variables are created right so
this is the blue no heart disease orange
heart disease and so some of the
synthetic are going over here into this
sparse so that's the general idea of how
the smoothing works so now once we have
our smoted
um data set we can now do our second
split which is into train and test right
and for that we're using the train
underscore test underscore split uh
method and I'll be using the X and the Y
as Arguments for that method we identify
the size of the split 0.3 would be the
test and then we give a random state so
when I run that I get now four
matrices X strain X test y train y test
so we're going to use x strain and Y
train to train our model and X test at y
test to test the performance of our
model
so before we actually
you know fit the model we're going to
standardize our data right because
these data points or these features we
we know from our when we did the box
plot we saw that the ranges for these
values were quite different you know for
example
um you know the age of course is going
from the 18 to 70 something but you have
things like blood pressure and others
going up into the hundreds so in that
case if we were to plot just the head
values here just to see what that looks
like right we can see age right so
that's kind of the ridge maybe if I did
a DOT to describe that would actually
give ranges yeah so age is ranging from
19 to 83 but when we look at some of the
other values in our data set for example
blood pressure is going from 70 to 196
blood sugar is going from
54 to 404 then of course these
interaction variables that are created
by combining two variables together they
even have a wider range the glucose BMI
interaction it is it has a maximum of uh
16 000 so the range is different so this
is why we are going to scale our
variables and make sure that they're all
in the same scale so we use the standard
scalar and that's going to
um convert all of the values to their
z-score so the values are going to be in
standard deviations essentially so we
create an instance of the standard
scalar
and we fit that on the train data set
and once we fit it we can then
transform all of the variable based on
those uh the the values in our standard
scalar model so this is what our values
now look like right so we have values
going from in this case
um there's no The Columns headings are
missing but you can see there's minus
1.8 and there is three so the values are
all in standard deviations right now
either one or two in some case three
standard deviations above the mean or
two or one point five standard
deviations below the mean so the range
is now much smaller so now that we've
scaled our variables so we have this x
underscore train underscore SC for
standards scale and now we can use that
in our model so we are going to do a
linear a logistic regression model
remember because our outcome is
categorical so we're using let's just
regenerating a logistic regression model
and the logistic regression model is
going to do a classification of yes or
no binary classification zero a one
heart disease or not
um so that's what the the logistic
regression is going to tell you now
there's a lot of
um some math and some integration
involved but just understand that it's
doing a classification
um we have identified the solar here as
the lib linear and we generate an
instance of the logistic regression
model once we've done that we can use
our data now we're using the X strain
scaled and the y train to fit our model
so let's run that and so now we have our
model and we can test the performance of
our model but now instead of the train
data set
we're going to use the test data set
right because we don't want to test the
model on the same data that was used to
train the data right because you know
we're going to get elevated
you know performance and not accurate
indication of how well our model will
generalize to data that it has not seen
before and that's the whole idea so now
we are going to use the test data set
but remember this model is built on
data that has been scaled
so we have to scale our test data as
well so we generate us another instance
of the standard scalar and we train it
on the test data set we don't want to
use the same standard scalar that we
trained with the train data set because
that's going to cause data leakage and
so the features of the the scalar from
the train model are going to be slightly
different so we want to treat this tests
data set as data fresh new data that's
coming in from who knows where that
we've not seen before so it's going to
be subject to its own set of values and
and inputs and so we are going to
standardize and get new features for our
scalar and then we will transform the
test data and once we have that X
underscore test underscore SC now we can
use that X test scale and our y test to
test the performance of our model and
what we do is we do model name DOT score
right so this is one of the attributes
that are built in with the logistic
model class and we can apply that
directly to our model and as long as we
put in the X values and the Y values it
is going to give you a result so what
it's going to do is it's going to take
the X test values and uh put it into our
model
and generate results
those are going to be our predicted
results
and then the algorithm will compare
how many times the predicted results
match the actual results in the white
test data and give us an accuracy score
and so that's what the results are and
we multiply by 100 to get 100 to get the
percentage so we run our model we do the
X test and then we get the score for our
model
so now
so now we can
use the X
test scaled and the white test to
test the performance of our model and
see what the accuracy
percentage is so in this case it's 76
percent
accurate
if we compare that with uh the train
data set we see that it's 77 percent
accurate so not much of overfitting
happening but those are the results such
four this is our base model then in the
next video we're going to look at ways
other ways we can test the performance
of our models using other metrics and
then even maybe some ways of improving
on the performance but the general idea
is you would get your data you would
separate the X from the Y as we did here
we had separate X and separate Y and we
then smote our data set if there is
imbalance is smooth if not you just move
right on to separating into train and
test once you've done that you scale the
Train the X train data and you use the
that to fit that instance of the model
that you generate so now you have your
model and once you have your model you
can now test the model but you've got to
scale the X data whatever you did to the
train you have to scale but with a
different instance of the uh standard
Scala and you then now use that scaled
data to test the performance of your
model so when we did our last uh version
of the model this was the accuracy score
77 so meaning every time we made a
measurement uh we we generated a
prediction using our Model 77 of the
times we correct we're correct the other
times we're not so we want to see if we
get improved on that accuracy score
somewhat right so remember these were
the values these were the features we
include included in our model the ones
that were
numerical float data types specifically
and these were the categorical mirrors
that that were left out so what I did
was I'm going to add some uh back some
of these variables that I think uh will
make a difference in terms of the
performance of the model so I think
gender is important I think diabetic
status is important as well as smoking
status so I'm going to add these back to
my working data frame right now when I
do that I'm going to notice that at
least one of them is categorical so we
can't use it in the model in that data
type so I'm going to so this is how it's
distributed non-diabetic and diabetic so
it's um you know categorical with text
labels so what I'm going to do is I am
going to change that and I'm going to
replace
these uh text labels with integers
right so now when I do my info I will
see here that indeed my diabetic status
is now of data type integer and so I can
use it in my model algorithm as such but
before doing so I want to generate a
plot of the correlation between each of
these features and the Target now this
is only going to look at
uh linear correlation and so it's you
know just kind of a measure
um and and this the graph is generating
generated showing uh the different
features and how they are
contributing the correlation between the
Target right so we can see age is very
strongly correlated whereas LDL
cholesterol is not so much HDL
cholesterol on the other hand
this is strongly correlated to not
having a heart disease whereas age is
strongly correlated to having heart
disease so as the age increases the
probability or the likelihood of a
disease increases whereas as the HDL
increases the probability of heart
disease goes down
um systolic blood pressure is strongly
correlated with having the disease and
so on and sex
um you know going from one sex to
another there is a stronger uh
possibility and I'm going to assume that
that's going from female to male
there is a stronger likelihood of
heart disease so I want to include these
measures namely gender diabetic status
smoking so that one is not as strong as
these two so hoping that by including
these two these three variables that we
would get a higher accuracy right so now
we have a new data frame with the
additional of columns so instead of the
19 that we had before 1890 we now have
21 so then our y value is still the same
and then now we can smote we're going to
do that over sampling of the minority
again and we are going to use that also
I did not
load my smooth
algorithm and let's go ahead and do that
it is inside here so I've done that so
now I can go back
to my uh smoting
and I can then create
that instance of the model and generate
my new X and my new y so now with the
new X and the new y I can now separate
so remember there are two two divisions
separating into X and Y and then
separating into train and test so now we
have our new train and test based on our
new X and Y
so now we can model
we create an instance of the logistic
regression model using the same solver
again and then we use this uh this is
our new model
um you know framework it's the
the blueprint
but first we have to of course scale our
data so we using the standard scalar
here and we create scaled versions of
the X and Y and just to show you what
that looks like so now we have these
values instead of age of 50 or 70 or
something we now have them in terms of
their standard deviation or their
z-score I should say
and so now we take these new X scale X
trained and the Y train and we fit the
model and now we are going to test the
model and this is my test for the model
I move that up here so we're using the
test
data set oh this way that's why this is
Hereford because we need to scale the
test value so we
fit our standard scalar on the X test
and then we transform all of the values
so those values now look
similar to what the trained Val extreme
values are and now that they're more
like that now we can put that into our
model and we can generate our
uh score
not much of an improvement it went from
77 to 78.
um and as far as the training set yeah
so not much of an improvement here but
you know that was we added some
variables that I thought were important
um didn't prove to be so much but we can
now look at some other things we can do
as far as our model is concerned using
some different
um
metrics right so we're going to do some
cross validation and remember
cross-validation is where we are
separating our model our data set into
test and train but doing so
um several times and changing what
values are in the train versus what's in
the Trap test so we're kind of mixing
things up as well so we created we need
the k-fold algorithm and we need our
cross ballast underscore uh score to to
use for the cross validation so we're
going to divide the data several times
over and then we're going to test that
the model each time and save the score
and then find the
ever
so I wanted to show an example of what
happens with the cross validation right
so if this is our data set we would
divide into the train and the test and
we would trade use this uh proportion of
the data set to train the model and then
this proportion and the yellow to test
the model then the next uh iteration we
would reserve a different proport
different
um set of observations for testing and
use these in the blue for the training
and then we will change that you know
depending on how many
um folds we have indicated in our data
so that's what that is so we have the
k-fold and the cross vowel that we are
loading in the data set so now we create
an instance of the k-fold we State how
many splits we want so here this is
um 10 this that's five splits we are
using
10 splits
um you know the splits of course the
more splits you have the more times you
will be running your your training but
you also have to take into consideration
the size of your data set and how long
each of these trainings are going to run
and how much computing power it's going
to utilize and you know different
factors so we are doing 10 splits so
instead of five we'll have ten and we're
creating a random state so if you want
to repeat what I'm doing you use the
same random State and should get the
same values and then we are saying
Shuffle is true so we're changing around
how the data is being split every time
right so that's what that does so we now
have our k-fold and then we have an
instance of the logistic regression
model
so now we're using our cross validation
here and we are going to use the model
that we created here and then we're
training it on the X string and Y train
and that should be our scaled data and
we're using the Y train so X train
scaled and Y train and then for the
cross validation we have this k-fold
object that has all the information in
there so when we run that we are going
to get a set of values so we ran 10
different models and each of them had a
different
accuracy score because that's the
default
metric that's been used so some had 77.9
of those one had 80 and then one had 76.
so the values are between like 75 for
the lowest accuracy
and
82 for the highest accuracy and on
average it had a mean of 78
accuracy with a standard deviation of
1.86
now we can use a different scoring
method other than the default accuracy
and here we're using the negative log
loss and we can run that with the same
parameters and here we see that the
average negative log loss is negative
0.47 with a standard deviation of
0.18 so that's another way of you know
measuring the performance of your
variable and you can then make changes
and use the same kind of
cross-validation again but we can also
change it to
um The ROC AUC or area under the curve
method of uh estimation because this is
a logistic regression and accuracy is
generally not the best method for
assessing the performance so if we use
the ROC AUC so now we're creating a
different model here retraining it and
I'm forgetting to make sure that this is
the scaled version
of
wait what am I doing
the scale the version
of my X strain
so let's see if that uh didn't make much
of a difference but here we have the X
strain and the ROC as the measure and so
it's given an RC score of
an AC score of 86 percent and so we can
look at that to see what that looks like
graphically so we're going to use the
confusion Matrix and the classification
report so the confusion Matrix that is
the Matrix that gives
um an account so I should have those in
there and make sure that I have one of
these models
as I rightly
called them
so after you've loaded the confusion
Matrix and the classification report you
can use them for different
representations of the different types
of metrics that you can use with your
logistic regression to evaluate the
performance of your logistic regression
so if we did the confusion if we did the
confusion Matrix using our X test and
the predicted y predicted y meaning the
values we would get from our model if we
put in the test values or the values
from our test data set that's been
scaled we get a set of values and we use
that to compare with the you know the
what the actual values are in the data
set and we would get we use it to
generate the confusion Matrix and this
syntax here is what is going to allow us
to view the confusion Matrix as such and
so we have our true positives here and
our true negatives and we have our false
negatives and our false positive so we
can see where the model
is doing well and where it is not and so
this gives us a further insight into our
model's performance and so we may care
more about one type of performance in
terms of whether we care more about the
Precision or the recall or maybe
um you know some balance of both right
and so we want to make sure that we're
doing that and when we have this
confusion Matrix now we can see where we
are now and in addition the um Precision
recall we can also get the F1 score so
we use the classification report again
with the Y test which is what is in the
actual data set and the predicted values
and so we can see what the Precision is
and the recall is for the one category
of the data and the same for the other
category of the data and then of course
we have the accuracy score and then we
have the macro average and the weighted
average so that's what the Precision rep
the classification report will tell us
and finally if we wanted to look at the
list of features and in terms of the
feature important so what we do here is
we are first going to get a list of the
features named from our column right so
now we have the names of all the
features that are included in our model
now we also can generate the
coefficients for each of these
um features in the model and we're using
lr1 in this case that's our model and so
this is the list of the coefficients
that correspond to each of these
features now to combine that into one
data frame right so firstly we are going
to
um
you know convert those
coefficients into an array then into a
list
as such and now once we have that list
we can use those two to the features and
the coefficients the names and create
two dictionary items right and that's
what we're doing here and then we can
change that into a data frame
and we will sort
by the coefficient values so this is
what it looks like here and so we see
that glucose is
um the most the glucose blood pressure
interaction is the strongest now it's
kind of hard to see all of them here so
then of course we can now that it is in
the form of a data frame it's easy to
plot that as a bar chart
and so I plot it as a bar chart and then
I've used the names of the features as
the X tick labels and this is what you
get so here we can see the contribution
of each of the features to the model's
performance so age is the strongest in
this case negative indication meaning
that as age increases you're more likely
to have a cardiovascular
disease so similarly the LDL cholesterol
interaction and HDL cholesterol
interaction those are strong
contributors then we have here and I
don't know why I have limited this to
17. let's change that so we can get the
names of all of them so now we have sex
as being
um possibly not the strongest so one of
the strongest age it seems It's the
strongest
um contributor to heart disease diabetic
status is also a strong contributor
smoking is a strong contributor now
remember when we did the linear
correlation it was not because the
correlation between smoking and heart
disease apparently is not linear but it
is strong and then fasting blood sugar
BMI and fasting blood sugar
cystolic systolic blood pressure so
that's how you would do that so remember
what I did I simply added back some of
the variables that I thought that might
have been important that God's left out
so I added smoking diabetic status and
sex and I didn't get much of an increase
in the accuracy of the model but it did
increase now we didn't measure things
like the uh precision and recall prior
to adding those so we don't know what
those changes might uh occur you know as
far as it concerned but we all we did
the cross validation tenfold and we got
the average values we also got the um
the net neg log loss we got the rocaut
score and we generated the plot for that
as well as the classification report and
then finally we did a table of picture
importance that we plotted on a graph so
that's how you would do your model
optimization so you can keep on further
tweaking and optimizing your model
adding some more variables taking away
others you know for example like we
could probably lose some of these uh
features here because they don't seem to
be contributing much to the model's
performance and just keep testing it and
see what happens but that's it in a
nutshell how you would do that now there
are other types of models besides the
logistic regression and maybe the next
video I will do a decision tree or
random forest and see how those perform
but so what is head speech any speech
that dispersed a group of people because
of their race religion nationality
national origin sexual orientation or
gender identity is considered as hate
speech
hate to speech is frequently used to
promote purgatory and hatred
additionally it can be applied to
threaten and intimate others
people may experience loneliness anxiety
and fear as a result
hate crimes may also result from it
additionally Health speech can harm
between various racial and ethnic groups
it is crucial to identify hate speech
using since doing so can assist in
stopping these negative impacts real
Learners if you want to upskill your AI
in machine learning skills so give
yourself a chance to Simply learn
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
the completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box below
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see if the answers given by you are
right.raw I'm repeating again here is
one question for you I will give you
exactly one minute for this you can
comment or you can give your answer in
the chat section so I I can see if your
answer given by your right or wrong
so the question is
all keywords in Python are capitalized
lowercase
uppercase and none
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
so I am starting the timer of one minute
okay
the time start now to let me know your
answers please
let's type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section
all python keywords are in
capitalize lowercase uppercase none
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
30 seconds remaining
all keywords in Python are capitalized
lowercase uppercase or none
the second small
keywords in Python are capitalized
lowercase uppercase and none
let us know your answer in the comment
section below please
five seconds more
after the allotted time has passed Those
Who provided the correct response will
receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
so now let's move to our programming
part
first we will open command prompt to
write a command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
Center
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you have to go new
python
this is the how the Jupiter kernel look
likes
so here
we will import some major libraries of
python which will help in analyzing the
data so here I will write import
ance
as PD
import
numpy
as NB
then from
Escalon
section
or text
counter vectorizer
okay
then one more storm
let's learn
model selection
it
will test underscore split
and from
SK learn
Audrey
import
ant
okay
okay counter vectorizer
account vectorizer it is
so numpy is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working with the domain of
linear algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stands for numerical
python
and pandas pandas is a software Library
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structure and operation for manipulating
numerical tables and Time series
this count vectorizer a fantastic
utility offered by the python
scikit-learn modulus count vectorizer
it is used to convert a given text into
a vector base on the number of times
like count that each word appears across
the full text
train test split
so our data is separated into train and
testing data using the trend test split
Technique we must first separate our
data into features X and label y divided
into X strain X text y train and Y test
the data frame is the model is trained
and fitted using extend and white train
sets okay then this is entry
a supervised machine learning algorithm
called decision tree uses a set of
principles to make judgments much like
how people do okay move forward let's
import some more libraries
so here I will write import
Ari then import
lltk
then from
ltk Dot
I will add here stammer
equals to nltk
Dot
mobile
okay
in English
that form nltk
purpose
upwards
okay then we'll write import
string
and I will assign stop word
equals to set
up words
and
English
foreign
okay
the function in the module allow you to
determine whether a given text fields
are given regular expression which is
known as a regular expression or re
or if a regular expression matches a
particular string which comes down to
the same thing
nltk the nltk toolkit was created for
python users to deal with NLP it offers
us numerous test data as data set and
different text processing libraries
using an ltk a range of activities can
be carried out including tokenizing and
visualizing parse trees
snowball stammer the stemming algorithm
also refers to as Porter 2 streaming
algorithm
is an improved version of potent stammer
because some of its shortcomings have
been addressed
okay so stop word a stop word is
frequently used um that a search engine
has been considered
both while indexing items for searching
and when retrieving them as a result of
search query
then import the string it is used to
determine whether or not substring is
part of the main string it gives back a
pointer to the first instance of S2 in
S1 I hope you guys understand till here
okay if you have any queries any
question regarding this please comment
down below
so after importing libraries let's
import our data set so I will write here
TF
equals to
PD Dot
data set name Twitter
data
okay
so
print
so this is the Twitter data set you can
download it from the description box
below and if you want to see the last
five rows instead of top five rows you
can use tail instead of head okay
moving forward I will add a new column
to this data set as labels which will
contain the values as HP is detected
offensive language detected or no hate
no offensive language detected
okay
for that I have to write here
DF
equals to DF
map
if
it's
detect
third one is
okay
the column so here I will add DF Dot
at
see
we have added labels
okay offensive luggage
moving forward now I will only select
the tweet and the label column for the
rest of the task of training a hate
speech detection model okay so here I
will add DF equals to DF
after that tweet
I guess yeah you can see here
tweet
comma
labels
right here DF dot head
as you can see
it okay so moving now I will create a
function to clean the text in the Tweet
column like this
that at the rate and this exclamation
these type of words
so here I will add
DF clean
text
equals to
HDR
x equals to
3 Dot substring
Dash this Dot
question mark
then
come on
and I will write here text equals to
re Dot substring
https
plus then
w w
it's Plus
get comma
text
okay here I will write text
to re Dot
subscribe
dot start
us
mama
yeah then let me
so here I will add text is equals to
re Dot substring
okay
dot punctuation
here again text equals to
read Dot substring
then
passion
for the next line
Obama
no d
w
ow
[Music]
text equals to
click on stop
that's equals one
and I will add DF then column in tweet
so DF
we have to add print
so everything will be clean like this
let me run it
okay so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code so please
comment down below so everything is
sorted now everything is clean
okay so moving forward now let's split
the data set into training and test that
and train a machine learning model for
the task of edit speech
okay so here I will write x equals to
P dot array
then DF
foreign
then DF
found
utilizer
here I will add x equals to
CV dot fit
for transform
X
okay
here I will write X underscore train
let's go test
again
okay that's cool test
X comma y comma
size
questions
state will be
25 equals to
BC
I will write classifier Dot
fit
okay let me run it
okay d
f
the season tree classifier sorry my bad
the input contains an n
okay there is one empty
it's working
so
moving forward now let's test this
machine learning model to see if it is
detecting say it is speech or not okay
so here I will write test
underscore
yeah
okay
so I will give one sentence here like
I
and d f equals to
transform
test underscore data
today
then here I will print
classifier
as you can see
it is which is detected because I will
kill you there is something hate on that
so let me write another sentence here
like
you
we run it
so here you can see no hate and
offensive speech you are also
so
private another one
like you
okay press enter
so here you can see it is not hit speed
but offensive language
okay
I hope you guys must already understand
how you can return hate speech using
machine learning if you have any queries
you can ask in the comment section below
our team will respond as soon as
possible
don't forget to check the course link
from the description box below and don't
forget to download the data set from the
description box and if you want to this
full code just comment for the same
what is fake news
pause or misleading information that is
reported as news is called fake news a
common goal or fake news is to harm
someone or something reputation or to
profit through advertising
the term fake news was first used in
1890s a time when dramatic newspaper
reports were common
even though incorrect information has
always been disamented throughout
history
however the phrase has no clear
definition and is often used to refer to
all misleading information high profile
individuals have also used it to refer
to any news that is not favorable to
them
so dear Learners if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skill so
give yourself a chance to Simply learn
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with a
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course details from the
description box below now let's move to
our programming part
so first we will open a command prompt
to write a command to open Jupiter
notebook so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
Center
and here I have to set new python kernel
file
okay so this is how the kernel look
likes
so first we will import some major
libraries of python so here I will write
import
ance as PD
and import
numpy
as NP
then
import
c bond
as SNS
and import
SK learn
dot model selection
port
train underscore
test the score split
before that
I will import
matplotlib
Dot pipelot
as PLT
okay then
I will write here from SK learn
Dot
Matrix
import
accuracy
or
than from
SK learn
dot matrix
Airport
classification
to report
and port
Ari then import
string
okay
then press enter
so it is saying
okay here I have to write from
everything seems good
loading let's see
okay till then numpa is a python Library
used for working with arrays which also
has function for working with domain of
lineal algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely
number stands for numerical python
pandas so panda is a software Library
written for Python programming language
for data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data structure and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and Time series
then seabon
an open source python Library based on
matplotlib is called C bone it is
utilized for data exploration and data
visualization
with data frames and the pandas Library
c-bond functions with ease
than matplotlib for Python and its
numerical extension numpy
matplotlib is a cross platform for the
data visualization and graphical
charting package
as a result it presents a strong open
source suitable for Matlab
the apis format plot live allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
GUI applications then this train test
split we may build our training data and
the test data with the aid of SQL and
train test split function
this is so because the original data set
often serves as both the training data
and the test data starting with a single
data set we divide it into two data sets
to obtain the information needed to
create a model like hone and test
accuracy score the accuracy score is
used to gauge the model's Effectiveness
by calculating the ratio of total true
positive to Total to negative across all
the model prediction
expression
the function in the model allow you to
determine whether a given text fits a
given regular occupation or not which is
known as re
okay then string a collection of letters
words or other character is called a
string it is one of the basic data
structure that serves as the foundation
of manipulating data
the Str class is a built-in string class
in Python because python strings are
immutable they cannot be modified after
they have been formed
okay so now let's import the data set we
will be going to import two data set one
for the fake news and one for the True
News or you can say not fake news
okay
so I will write here
EF underscore
pick
pursue
PD Dot
read underscore CSV
or what can I say DF fake
okay
it underscore fake
okay
then
fake dot CSV
you can download this data set from the
description box below
then data Dot
true
equal to PD dot read
underscore CSV
sorry CSV
then
big news sorry true
dot CSV
okay then press enter
so these are the two data set
you can download these dataset from the
description box below so let's see the
board data set okay
then I will write here data underscore
fake
dot head
so this is the fake data okay then
data underscore true
Dot
and this is the two data
okay this is not fake so if you want to
see your top five rows
of the particular data set you can use
head
and if you want to see the last five
rows of the data set you can use tail
instead of head
okay
so let me give some space for the better
visual
so now we will insert column class as a
Target feature okay then I will write
here data
let's go fake
Plus
equals to zero
then
data underscore true
and
Plus
was one
okay
then
I will write here data underscore fake
dot shape
and
data underscore through
dot ship
okay then press enter
so the shape method return the shape of
an array the shape is a tuple of
integers these number represent the
length of the corresponding array
dimension in other words a tuple
containing the quantities of entries on
each axis is an array shape dimension so
what's the meaning of shape
in the fake world
in this data set we have two three four
eight one rows and five columns and in
this data set true
we have two one four one seven rows and
five column okay so these are the rows
column rows column for the particular
data set
so now let's move
and let's remove the last 10 rows for
the manual testing okay
then I will write here data underscore
fake
let's go manual
testing
question
data underscore fake
dot tail
for the last 10 rows I have to write
here 10.
okay so for I
in range
two three four
eight one
sorry zero
comma 2 3
4 7 0
comma minus 1.
okay
and
TF underscore not DF data
underscore fake
dot drop
one
instead of one I can write here I
comma
this is equals to zero
place
equals to true
then
data
not here
data underscore
same I will write for I will copy from
here
and I will paste it here
and I will make the particular changes
so here I can write true
that I can write true
okay
then I have to change a number
two one
416
right
2 1
4 0 6
-1
same
so press enter
X is equals to zero
pellets insects maybe you mean double
zero or of this
okay we will put here double course
and I'm putting this
take dot drop i x is equals zero okay in
place okay
they're also at equals to an equation
yeah
so
okay axis is not defined
now it's working so
let me see
now
did the underscore
fake dot shape
okay
and data dot true
and
data underscore true
dot shape
as you can see
10 rows are deleted from each data set
yeah
so I will write here data underscore
fake underscore manual
testing
class
equals to zero
and data underscore
true
let's go
manual underscore testing
plus equals to
one
okay
just ignore this warning
and
let's see
data underscore
fake underscore
manual
testing dot head
as you can see we have this
and then data dot sorry underscore true
underscore
manual
testing
dot at
this is this is the uh true data set
so here I will merge data
let's go merge
for sure
PD Dot
concat
concat is used for the concatenation
data underscore fake
data underscore
comma
axis
equals to zero
then data underscore merge
dot head
the top 10 rows
yeah
as you can see the data is merged
here
first it will come for the fake news and
then with that for the True News
and let's merge true and fake data
frames
okay
we did this and
let's merge the column then data dot
merge
Dot
columns or let's see the columns
it is not defined whatever data
underscore much
these are the column same title text
subject date class okay
now
let's remove those columns which are not
required for the further process
so here I will write data underscore
or equal to
data underscore merge
crop
title we don't need
that
subject
we don't need then
so one
so let's check some null values
it's giving here
because of this
that's good then data
dot is null
dot sum
Center
so no null values
okay
then
let's do the random shuffling of the
data frames okay
for that we have to write here data
equals to
data dot sample
one
then
data
okay
data
dot hat
okay now you can see here the random
shuffling is done
and one for the
true data reset and zero for the fake
news one okay
then
let me write here data Dot
reset
underscore index
place
because you
true
data dot drop
comma axis
equals to 1
then comma in place
equals to true
okay
then let me see columns now data Dot
columns
so here we have two columns only rest we
have deleted
okay
so
let me see data dot add
yeah
everything seems good
let's proceed further and let's create a
function to process the text okay
for that I will write here
but
okay
you can use any name
text
and text equal to
text Dot lower
okay
and text
equal to re dot for the substring
remove these things
from the
datas
okay
so for that I'm writing here
comma
okay
then text equals to
re Dot substring
comma
comma text
okay
then I have to write text equals to
r dot substring
to www
Dot
S Plus
comma
comma text
okay then text equals to
re Dot substring
then
oh
comma
okay
then text equals to
re Dot substring
and
percentage
as
again percentage or
RG dot SK function
right here string
dot punctuation
comma
and Gamma then text
right
then text equals to re Dot substring
and and
comma
x equals
re Dot
substring
right here
and again d
then again
then comma
and again
texture
okay then at the end after right here
return text so everything like uh this
these type of special character will be
removed from the data set
okay let's run this let's see
yeah so here I will add DF sorry not DF
data
data
then
text
pursue
data
okay dot apply
to the function name what part word opt
okay
press enter
yeah
so now let's define the dependent and
independent variables okay x equals to
data
text
and Y equals to
data
class
okay
then splitting training and testing data
okay sorry
so here I will write X underscore train
comma X underscore test
then y underscore train
comma y underscore test equals to
train underscore test underscore split
then X comma y
comma test
let's go size equals to
0.25
okay press enter
so now let's convert text to vectors
for that I have to write here
that it's X
so here I will write from sqlarn
Dot feature
extraction
Dot text import
t
factorizer
okay
then vectorization
equals to g f i t
factorizer
okay
then
it's V
underscore
train
equals to
vectorization
or reset it t i 100 factorization dot
fit
then transform
X underscore train
okay
then XV underscore test equals to
factorization
condition
Dot transform
X underscore test
okay then press enter
[Music]
so now let's see our first model
logistic regression
so here I will write
from
sqln Dot
linear underscore model
okay import
logistic
regression
then a lot goes to
logistic
regression
and I have to write here LR Dot
split
then XV
Dot
not DOT so dot train
comma
x v underscore test
okay
press enter
dot XV dot train
okay here I have to write y train
and press enter
we work so here I will write prediction
underscore
linear regression
l r dot predict
XV underscore test
okay let's see the accuracy score
for that I have to write LR DOT score
then XV underscore test
comma y underscore test
okay
let's see the accuracy so here as you
can see accuracy is quite good 98
percent
now let's print
the classification
code
y underscore test comma
prediction of linear regression
okay
so this is you can see Precision score
then F1 is code then support value
accuracy
okay
so now we will do this same for the
decision free gradient boosting
classifier random for this classifier
okay then we will do model testing then
we will predict this score
okay so now for the decision tree
classification so for that I have to
import from SK learn
Dot 3
import
decision
three
classifier
okay
then at the short form I will write here
I will copy it from here
then
okay
then I have to write same as this so I
will copy it from here
and
let's change linear regression
to
season 3 classified
okay
then I will write here same
let's go DT
question
DT dot predict
XV underscore
test
e
still loading it's it will take time
okay
till then let me write here for the
accuracy
DT DOT score
three underscore test
comma y
let's wait okay
let's run
the accuracy
so as you can see accuracy is good than
this linear regression
okay logistic regression
okay so let me
show you deep let me predict
trend
okay
so this is the accuracy score this is
the all the report
yeah
so now let's move for the gradient
boosting classifier
okay for that I've read from
sqlan
dot ensemble
port
gradient
boosting
classifier
pacifier
I will write here GB
because you let me copy it from here
I will give here random
let's go state
equals to zero
wait wait wait wait so I will write here
GB Dot
fit
three underscore train
comma
y underscore chain okay then press enter
here I will write predict
underscore GB
was who
GB Dot
wait sorry
predict
three
DOT test
dot dot underscore test
till then it's loading so I will write
here uh it's for this code then I will
add GB DOT score
that
three underscore test
comma
y underscore test
okay
so let's wait it is running this part
till then let me write for the
printing this
case taking time
taking time still taking time
but if I will run this
it's not coming because of this
yeah it's done now so you can see the
accuracies
not good then
decision tree but yeah it is also good
99
.4 something okay so
now let's check for the last one random
Forest
first I will do
for the random folders We have to write
from sqlarn Dot
symbol
import
random
Forest
classifier
okay
and here I will write RF
was to right I will copy it from here
then
random
date
equals to
zero
and
RF Dot
fit
three underscore train
comma y underscore train
okay then press enter
and predict
underscore
RC
or F
equals to
RF dot predict
C underscore test
okay
till then I will write it still loading
it will take time so till then I will
write for the score score accuracy score
XV underscore test comma y underscore
test
okay
then I will write here till then print
classification
code
and Y underscore test
comma
it will take time little bit
so
it run the accuracy score is 99 it is
also good
so now I will add the code for the model
testing
so I will get back to you
but after writing the code so
so I have made two functions one for the
output label and one for the manual
testing okay
so it will predict
the all the from the all models from the
repeat so it will predict
the the news is fake or not from all the
models okay
so for that
let me write
here news
also string
put
okay
then I will let him manual underscore
testing
so
here I will you can add any news from
the you can copy it from the Internet or
whatever from wherever you want
so I'm just copying from the internet
okay from the Google
the news
which is not fake okay I'm adding which
is not fake because I already know I
searched on Google
so I'm entering this
so just run it let's see what is showing
okay
string input object is not callable okay
let me check this first
a I have to give here Str only
yeah let's check
okay I have to add here again the Escape
yeah
manual testing is not defined
let me see manual testing
okay I have to edit something
it is just GB and it is just RF
and GPS is not defined okay okay
so what I have to do
I have to remove this
this
everything seems sorted
now
as I said to you
I just copied this news from the
internet I already know the news is not
fake so it is showing not a fake news
okay so now what I will do I will copy
one fake news from the internet
and let's see it is detecting it or not
okay
so let me run this
and let me add the news for this
so
all the models are predicting right it
is a fake news
or you can add your own script like this
is the fake news okay
I hope you guys understand
till here
so I hope you guys must have understand
how to detect a fake news using machine
learning you can you can copy it any
news from the internet and you can check
it is fake or not okay or if your model
is predicting right or not so if you
have any queries you can ask in the
comment section below our team will
respond you as soon as possible okay
don't forget to check the coursing from
the description box below and you can
download this data set from the
description box below
and if you want this full code
full code just comment for the same so
we came to end of this video if you have
any queries you can ask in the comment
section below our team will respond to
you as soon as possible and if you want
this full code just comment for the same
thank you so much for being here if you
enjoyed this video please do subscribe
to our YouTube channel and give like to
this video thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here